Você sabia que o acúmulo de proteínas no
cérebro como a tal e a Beta amiloide não
é a verdadeira causa do Alzheimer
estudos recentes revelam que na verdade
essas proteínas podem ser respostas
protetoras do cérebro para combater
danos subjacentes Neste vídeo Vamos
explorar como isso pode mudar
completamente a maneira como entendemos
e tratamos essa doença tão temida Vamos
começar com a proteína tal por anos ela
foi vista como uma vilã acumulando-se em
nosso cérebro e causando o declínio
cognitivo no entanto novas pesquisas
indicam que a tal desempenha um papel
protetor fundamental quando nossas
células cerebrais enfrentam o estresse
oxidativo a tal ajuda a formar gotículas
lipídicas que atuam como escudos
absorvendo lipídios tóxicos e protegendo
os neurônios mas não é só isso a Beta
amiloide tão temida por ser associada a
placas prejudiciais também parece ter um
papel importante na defesa do cérebro
ela atua como um antioxidante e ajuda a
proteger as regiões cerebrais mais
ativas No entanto quando essa proteção
se torna exagerada o acúmulo de Beta
amiloide pode se transformar em um
problema e aqui está a parte mais
interessante a saúde do nosso cérebro
está profundamente mente conectada à
saúde do nosso intestino estudos mostram
que bactérias benéficas no intestino
podem ajudar a controlar a inflamação um
dos principais fatores que desencadeiam
os danos que o Alzheimer tenta combater
no entanto dietas ricas em óleos de
sementes e outras substâncias
prejudiciais podem destruir esse
equilíbrio comprometendo nossa saúde
cerebral com esse novo entendimento fica
claro que o Alzheimer é uma resposta do
cérebro a problemas subjacentes como
inflamação e disfunção intestinal por
isso é essencial adotarmos uma abordagem
holística para proteger nosso cérebro e
prevenir a doença se você quer aprender
mais sobre como prevenir o Alzheimer de
forma natural e eficaz inscreva-se no
canal E compartilhe este vídeo com quem
você ama Vamos juntos promover um
envelhecimento saudável e consciente